Tenemos una balanza aquí que, como puedes ver,
está en equilibrio, y aquí hay algo que quiero
que resolvamos. Tenemos esta masa misteriosa
azul con un gran signo de interrogación y también
tenemos un montón de masas de 1 kilogramo, todos
estos objetos tienen una masa de 1 kilogramo,
y mi pregunta para ti es ¿qué podríamos hacer a
cada lado de esta balanza para descubrir a qué
equivale la masa misteriosa o tal vez no podemos
resolverlo en absoluto?, ¿hay algo que podamos
hacer ya sea agregando o quitando estas cosas para
descubrir a qué es igual esta masa misteriosa? Te
daré un par de segundos para que lo pienses. Para
descubrir a qué es igual esta masa misteriosa,
básicamente queremos dejarla sola en un lado de
la balanza, pero eso por sí sólo no es suficiente,
podríamos simplemente eliminar estos tres pero
eso no funcionará porque si sólo eliminamos
estos tres entonces el lado izquierdo de esta
balanza claramente tendrá menos masa y subirá,
y el lado derecho va a bajar, sólo nos dirá
que la masa de este objeto azul es menor que
la que está de este otro lado, por lo que
solamente quitar esto no nos ayudará mucho,
no nos dirá que este lado es igual a este otro.
Lo que tenemos que hacer para mantener la balanza
equilibrada es quitar la misma cantidad
de masa de ambos lados de la balanza,
entonces si queremos eliminar tres cosas aquí
-permíteme tratar de eliminar tres cosas aquí-,
si queremos eliminar tres cosas no podemos
quitarlas y ya, porque ahora los dos lados
ya no tendrían la misma masa, este lado
tendría una masa menor. Entonces tenemos
que quitar tres cosas de ambos lados, si queremos
asegurarnos de que nuestra balanza se mantenga
equilibrada tenemos que quitar tres cosas
de ambos lados. Si comenzamos con la balanza
equilibrada y luego quitamos 3 kilogramos de
ambos lados, la balanza seguirá equilibrada,
y entonces tendríamos una idea clara de cuál
es la masa de este objeto misterioso. Como
eliminamos 3 kilogramos de cada lado, la balanza
seguirá equilibrada y ahora sabemos que esta más
es igual a lo que queda aquí, es igual a 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, y entonces sabremos que
la masa misteriosa es igual a 7 kilogramos,
entonces esta es una masa de 7 kilogramos.